president zielinski landing in Japan
stepping into the arms of the world's
most powerful democracies
on the sidelines of the summit waiting
in the wings to embrace the support of
key partners
the U.S promised that allies will supply
F-16 fighter jets in his words a
historic moment
are you closer to peace now sir for this
President a major move in Ukraine's
quest to end this war it's a good day
isn't it a good day
and these leaders no doubt agree
standing United against Russian
aggression
the geopolitical Outlook so far from
Bright but I hope that peace will
prevail these allies hand in glove ready
to support Ukraine my word is to say
that from the very beginning you know
that France is that shoulder to shoulder
with you we are here and we will be here
to the very end be sure about that I
thank you for all this support and we
spoke a lot about about future Jazz
collection and I want to thank you and
all the partners about this decision
about training mission is really really
very very important
close allies and firm friends
who have put in the time and effort to
make sure they're aligned not just on
Ukraine but on future threats too the G7
leaders also condemning an increasingly
muscular China expressing serious
concern over the economic and Military
danger Beijing poses in the final Summit
statement
as these democracies defend their ground
back in the days of Donald Trump and
Boris Johnson g7s were more often than
not punctuated by division but allies
here have sought to portray a united
front against common threats standing
literally shoulder to shoulder with
president zielinski and Ukraine whilst
also issuing a joint statement
criticizing China's increasing economic
and Military aggression no time to look
away Russia absent but acutely aware of
what's going on here tonight say in the
west decision to provide Jets is a
colossal risk but one allies are willing
finally to take Beth Rick B Sky News in
Hiroshima